so this is a question that I got from Princeton
if you ever come across a question like this
if you have a wider base
and today we're talking population pyramids
for you to know what the birth and mortality rates are
just the population pyramid itself is not enough
so you can go ahead and eliminate B and D
is anything having to do with birth rate or death rate
so you don't know if it's likely to increase or decrease
I've never seen this before the MCAT
so this was something that I never learned in any of my like pre med classes
then the overall size of the population is likely to increase
then the population is likely to decrease
and if you have a narrower base
and the trick that I learned is to basically cover up everyone that's like
so now you have A and C
but it's not as difficult as it seems
meaning you have more people in their twenties and thirties
the answer choices that you can automatically eliminate
meaning you have more younger people than people in their twenties and thirties
40 and above and only look at people 0-34
back with another MCAT tip